Hi everybody you're on fire ched. Ched started to
bring it up i said don't bring it up why would
i tell you to bring it up sorry uncle moe she
already feels like complete crud it's okay dad
i yes got fired but it's fine is the nicest young
man who works at the coffee shop that i go to his
name is you so not sent me in no no he's much
too young for you no he wants to be a superhero
and i told him that my daughter was a superhero
he hadn't heard of you but i gave him your
number so that he could call you for advice
please stop giving my number out to strangers
again uh that hawkeye guy what happens to
those arrows of his i mean does he go around
and collect them when he's done government the
u.s bureau what am i supposed to do with this
god i've god i hope he's got a dongle arrow to make this useful
jenny nobody calls me that i'm just
gonna put this out there melanie
is a stylist you know she could help you
let's get this hair more like she-hulks
so back to hawkeye it's pretty hazardous
to believe those things lying around
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this will be
my new she-hulk video marvel just released a new
trailer with her having a family dinner explaining
a couple big questions that they raised during
episode one also really nice to hear them talking
about other big avengers heroes in the universe
they kind of do that in a lot of different marvel
movies in marvel disney plus series where you have
a lot of casual like just normal people on the
street talking about the avengers shanxi's friends
at the beginning of that movie even talked about
thanos in the snap we're now living in a world
where at any moment half the population can just
disappear most of the major stuff around avengers
end game is public knowledge at this point that's
why everybody knows about thanos the snap all the
avengers heroes they're basically celebrities
at this point in the world but there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs here we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes i will
be doing videos for all the she-hulk episodes
it's not really clear when this scene takes
place during the episode probably pretty early on
but it's after the trial that she was having at
the end of episode one where titania just crashed
in and caused all this havoc the way they played
the episode they made it sound like she actually
won that particular case but apparently she got
fired by the district attorney's office so maybe
she wound up losing or maybe they just hated
the idea of her becoming she-hulk either way
they had to create a reason for her to be hired
by glk and h this person here he's actually one
of the partners of the firm holloway the actual
name of the law firm is a big easter egg for the
founding of marvel comics in real life the full
name of the law firm is goodman lieber kurtzberg
in holloway which is a reference to martin goodman
he's the original owner of the company that will
become marvel like he owned timely comics that
would eventually rename itself to atlas comics
and eventually renamed itself to marvel comics as
you know it today he's also the person who hired
a very young stan lee there are easter eggs for
him all over marvel comics martin goodman that is
marvel movies marvel disney plush shows like there
was just an easter egg that we spotted during loki
season 2 in an episode for goodman productions
who's an in-universe movie company making b-movies
in the 1970s who make this zaniak movie amongst
other movies which themselves are either based on
actual characters from real-life marvel comics
super meta like zaniak himself here is an actual
marvel character or they're fake movies with
titles that are references to real life marvel
movies or characters lieber is a reference to
stan lee's real name he was originally named
stanley lieber like that's still his legal name
but for professional purposes like way back in
the day he created the stanley name kurzberg is
a reference to jack kirby that was his original
legal name when he was born he also changed it
later in life like stan lee did in holloway isn't
a big reference to a real life person in marvel
comics he's just another partner at the law firm
played by this actor here like this is holloway
during episode two he's probably going to recruit
jennifer walters she-hulk to work for the firm's
superhero division and defend the abomination it's
like her first real big case he did the same thing
in the comics basically but the whole idea is that
they hire her to run their new superhero division
defending super villains and superheroes alike
but when she comes to dinner you have her father
here asking her all these hawkeye questions like
what happens to all of hawkeye's arrows which
is meant to be a reference to the hawkeye series
where they very literally answer that question
kate bishop literally talks to hawkeye about that
like what happens to all your arrows and he's like
this is what happens i go back and i pick them up
they did have a couple deleted scenes where he was
making some of his special arrows they gave you
a little bit of that montage hawkeye was one of
those disney plus series that they filmed during
the virus and thus ended up having a bunch of
big changes because it was a big pause during
filming so they changed a bunch of story lines
and moved things around and there were a bunch
of deleted scenes i've already done several
videos about all those like a lot of kingpin
deleted scenes too so i'll post links for those
in the description below we'll get plenty more
kingpin during daredevil born again we're gonna
see him in the echo series before that too he'll
be like a really big character during that just
because of the character's relationship with
the echo character like matt murdock daredevil is
obviously coming back during the she-hulk episodes
cannot wait to see that happen but he's also
coming back during echo too it'll be a little
bit bigger of a cameo but then obviously we have
daredevil born again where it'll be like all just
them the other big connection between she-hulk
and the hawkeye series are the tracksuit bros we
saw an easter egg for them during the miss marvel
series too because that took place in jersey city
not too far from where the events of hawkeye were
taking place in manhattan there was a tracksuit
bros truck driving through jersey city in the
end credits of all the miss marvel episodes so
it just meant that the tracksuit bros were
active around this area like he's starting
to amass more and more power and that's going to
culminate during the daredevil born again series
but at least in the footage that we've seen so far
the connection to the tracksuit bros on she-hulk
is all through that fake tinder app she uses for
her dating profile as she hulk when she starts
posting on it in the trailer you see her looking
at all the comments one of the comments is from a
tracksuit bros profile like the tracksuit bros
are huge fans of she-hulk now that's funny for
like a couple different reasons but mostly i
think because the idea that you have a bunch of
supervillains doing really terrible stuff but they
love really hot looking superheroes like they'll
probably like this with a bunch of other really
good looking superheroes as well too like there
were photos of black widow on social media the
tracksuit bros would probably be all over that
too if she were still alive one of the women of
the avengers gonna make that swimsuit calendar
i'm sure the tracksuit bros would probably be
like their best customers for all that merch
you also might recognize the person playing her
father if he looks familiar it's mark lynn baker
from the perfect strangers sitcom but they're also
playing this show in a comedic kind of way kind
of like fleabag meets better call saul that's what
the show runners said were mostly their influences
flea bag and better call saw one because of the
fourth wall breaking that you see in fleabag
but also because it's a mixture of dramatic and
really comedic things as well as better call saul
which is like a pure lawyer show with a little
bit of comedy like really dark comedy but also
that whole aspect where he's dealing with a lot
of really really shady people which is basically
what she's doing having to defend people like the
abomination and other super villains the other big
thing that they reveal here is what's going on
with the ched character that they name drop in
episode one so when the two of them were talking
in the car before their big accident they were
talking about all the geniuses in the family and
they mentioned ched being another one too making
it sound like he was a genius but i couldn't tell
if they were being sarcastic because the way he's
acting in this clip here he's giving off much more
of a laid-back stoner dude vibe as opposed to like
your traditional geniuses in the mcu like bruce
banner tony stark even shuri even though they quit
they tell jokes they're more like traditional
geniuses the other connection to geniuses the
hulk characters a lot of people were asking about
was an amadeus cho character because he's big in
the whole comics it's totally possible that they
try to eventually introduce that character though
because they're trying to introduce so many new
hulk characters but just in terms of the bruce
banner hulk being around long term because they
did try to pass the mantle briefly it sounds like
bruce banner is going to be around well through
avengers 6 secret wars so he's not going anywhere
anytime soon and we've been talking a lot about
world war hulk arcs in the mcu so they were to
do a version of amadeus cho it'd be like something
a little bit different going on with the character
the other big reveal that they made is that the
titanium storyline at the end of episode one where
like she just crashes into the trial and goes
after jennifer walter she-hulk they won't actually
directly follow up on in a really big way until
episode five like titania doesn't appear again
until episode 5. there were also a lot of funny
real world promos that they had with the actress
going around in full character like she was in
full makeup acting as the character just painting
over all the she-hulk billboards and ads that
they have around town but because the actress was
also talking about the thunderbolts while she was
talking about her early arc during she-hulk they
might also spin up to larger avengers level stuff
with her character by the end of the series and i
think some of that will flow with what's happening
with the wong character on the series and
obviously the way that they leave the daredevil
character when he comes on too like it'll be
relatively day-to-day stuff that she helps them
with when they first come on but then it'll become
a much much bigger thing the mother also mentioned
a person she ran into during the day that wants to
be a superhero so i'm also wondering if he's gonna
be one of the people to come see her later like
one of the minor c or d list super villains or
superheroes a lot of the ones that we've seen in
the trailer like during the abominations meetings
here are actually daredevil villains or punisher
villains which obviously just reminds you of
all the marvel netflix characters like of course
they're going to be doing a lot of daredevil and
punisher-related characters because most of those
characters are coming back during daredevil born
again we already know that jessica jones is also
going to be coming back during that i don't know
if she's going to show up during the she-hulk
episodes though but i do think that we will see
her or at least some plot with her during the
echo series like a teaser and then for real like
she'll actually come on screen during daredevil
born again no promises on iron fist though like
we make all the iron fist jokes like everybody
coming back to the mcu no wait not you iron fist
you sit down but if you spotted any other easter
eggs during this just write them below in the
comments in my full she-hulk episode 2 video
will post next make sure you enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click here
for my full she-hulk episode 1 video and click
here for my full house of the dragon episode1
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!